todo sigue con normalidad en los puertos
franceses pero por cuánto tiempo ante el
temor de que el gobierno de manuel mayor
pudiera imponer sanciones a las flotas
pesqueras y a las mercancías británicas
los pescadores y las empresas francesas
temían un efecto adverso en sus propias
actividades
van a responder con medidas fuertes si
ejercemos presión
así que creen que se deben calmar las
cosas si lo creemos la mayoría de los
productos que vende este pescadero
proceden de reino unido son vitales para
su negocio
serpa son
estos productos vienen de escocia este
también aquí tienes varias toneladas de
salmón salmón que viene desde escocia
básicamente el 70% de nuestro stock
tiene escocia cada día
si francia impusiera sanciones se
aplicarían más controles a los productos
británicos las empresas francesas que
venden productos británicos creen que
estos controles sólo harían que la
mercancía llegará con retraso y
probablemente no tan fresca si la
mercancía llega tarde estos productos
son muy frágiles
se puede conservar un poco más pero los
langostinos hay que venderlos enseguida
el mayor temor en este caso es que los
clientes busquen sus productos en otra
parte si los pedidos se retrasan vale el
riesgo es que los clientes se lleven su
negocio a otra parte el riesgo es que
tengamos menos productos que vender
porque no tenemos mercancía que venga al
reino unido
wyoming y el 30% de los ingresos
pesqueros franceses proceden de aguas
británicas